[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'anciens on
parler sport c'est le huitième numéro
deux cette saison sur tb soixante dix
huit essais la dernière émission déjà
enregistré en 2021 au programme comme
toujours une dose de bonne humeur des
abbayes sportive et surtout des coups de
gueule et des débats nos chroniqueurs
sont avec nous sur ce plateau
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite vous le connaissez tous si nous
vient tout droit des contrées
versaillaise il est venu avec sa dose de
bonne humeur et une volonté de débattre
comme à d'habitude pierre chevalier du
rugby-club de versailles est avec nous
pendant une heure ça l'unique salut à
tous quand allez-vous pierre fort bien
dans cette petite forêt yvelinoise
magnifique avec cette décoration festive
on est bien on est déjà dans la joie de
noël voilà on a deux 2 jours de travail
deux jours encore de dodo et ça arrive
vous attendez les cadeaux oui beaucoup
de cadeaux
j'espère vous êtes et sage on continue
notre tour de table musique c'est sa
deuxième apparition dans ce talk il a
travaillé à la fédération française de
golf à la fédération française de
cyclisme aujourd'hui c'est le monsieur
jeux olympiques à 50 en libye mesdames
et messieurs 1re courtier est avec nous
pendant une heure bonjour comment allez
voir le merveilleusement bien on va
parler sport cela plus beaux sujets
qu'ils soient alors les préparatifs des
jeux à saint quentin en yvelines ça
avance ça avance très bien même oui
absolument vous êtes sur le dossier à
fond et on est plusieurs sont aussi en
afrique absolument non toi bien alors on
continue à ma droite musique lui aussi
est une légende
de cette émission c'est un spécialiste
basket famille s'y connaît dans tous les
sports il joue dans le club de basket de
trappes il a une grande expérience
internationale notre fbi magic mike beau
congo est avec nous pendant une heure
bonjour nickel bonjour à tous comment
allez-vous il dit très bien être
de quoi
alors là c'est la dernière émission de
l'année vous attend dès 2022 avec
impatience oui oui monsieur monsieur
mais après on va passer un bon moment je
pense que on a de belles choses à paris
on termine bien 2009 on sent alors avant
de passer au programme de l'émission a
parlé de rugby emilie boulot génère de
rambouillet a reçu un prix de la part de
world rugby la fédération internationale
attribuée à emilie goulard le prix du
plus bel essai de l'année on va regarder
tout de suite et s'est inscrit faso un
pays galles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors votre avis tout simplement sur cet
essai on va déjà s'adresser aux
spécialistes pierre chevallier j'en
avais inscrit beaucoup on est comme ça
oui mais plein déployés comme ça surtout
surtout avec le numéro 15 dans le dos ça
c'est sûr j'en ai marqué des tonnes
de deux choses là qui me viennent assez
vite c'est premièrement c'est les
souvenirs de ces stades vides ils sont
et qui était tellement triste pendant
pendant la pandémie ou pas beaucoup de
public
cause que vides et puis deuxièmement ça
me fait penser ça me rappelle les très
belles saisons qu'un qu'a réalisé
l'équipe de france de rugby féminine
notamment avec deux fois le scalp des
redoutables blacks ferns les néo
zélandaise et donc c'est très bien en
plus que c'était s'est distingué soit
marqué collectivement évidemment parce
que c'est rugby s'est terminé il ya une
action collective ligne mais il faut
être au bon endroit pour le retour
intérieur et c'est très bien car je
remarque epargne-vie noise d'origine et
s'assigne vraiment bien ce magnifique
sport collectif qu'est le rugby par le
courtier qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'ai pas mêmes compétences rugbystiques
comment camarades mais non bel essai
magnifique elle est allée à la fin elle
est allée au début aussi il semble en
fait et puis s'est construit et puis une
reconnaissance sur une joueuse française
de toute manière on est preneur quoi
qu'il se passe mike est un sport co
quand même c'est à dire toujours cette
habitude de travailler ensemble de
formes et lécher mon équipe donc encore
ses skis à ce qu'on a pu voir sur sur
cette action 1 donc c'était magnifique à
voir à la 21 ans emilie boulard la
toussaint car adorait on peut lire vis
de la vie inc est une belle carrière
devant de vente elle a joué au club de
chilly-mazarin de vie à 2017 chili et là
aussi il faut il faut il faut préciser
que l'île de france est un est un
formidable vivier de joueuses et joueurs
de rugby il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
notamment d'international féminine
internationaux masculins qui sont qui
sont issus des clubs des clubs
franciliens pas tous des yvelines certes
mais on a énormément de belles écoles de
rugby
dans les yvelines évidemment j'en sais
je sais de quoi je parle de très belles
écoles de rugby mais aussi dans l'est
dans les départements franciliens et et
là on a on a de beaux espoirs chez les
féminines et g chez les garçons armes
courtes et ça peut peut-être vous
intéressez à la fête du rugby à 7 et
elle veut participer aux jeux olympiques
en 2024 qu'est ce que vous en pensez
lucas la raison
et on lui souhaite d'être d'être au
rendez vous bien sûr oui c'est un de ses
rêves voilà exactement rugby et alors je
sais pas si je vais me faire des amis
mais qui soit 15 à 7 ou à 13 ça reste du
rugby
et que et que voilà
que la france et une à une une des
grandes nations du rugby dessous manière
historiquement en 2024 cette chance
extraordinaire d'avoir les jeux chez
nous et j'espère que les françaises et
les français dans ce sport là seront
présents et au plus haut niveau bien sûr
la dernière question sur emilie bull a
elle fait partie un petit peu de cette
génération des nouveaux rugbyman qui
arrive au niveau professionnel et
notamment chez les filles fille ou
garçon notamment chez les filles et
c'est vrai que alors évidemment comme le
comme le rugby des garçons a bénéficié
de plus de médiatisation on peut suivre
depuis plus longtemps les générations
qui arrivent hélas là tout doré qui est
qui a été championne du monde vivant il
n'y a pas si longtemps et qui arrive
maintenant en équipe de france en équipe
une en équipe de france mais c'est vrai
aussi pour le pour les filles qui ont
été à la fois à la fois attirer et
intéresser par le rugby sur les récents
résultats des équipes de france chez les
et chez les garçons c'est vrai et chez
les filles c'est vrai aussi avec la
médaille d'argent aux jo de tokyo à 7 et
donc c'est une formidable formidable
lucarne pour prendre 22
un mode football formidable 15 sur la
pratique ces fameuses valeurs d'ovalie
qui font que le rugby à de belles années
devant lui alors nous allons maintenant
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du tirage
au sort de la ligue des champions le psg
affrontera le real madrid en 8e de
finale coup de projecteur également sur
la cérémonie d'ouverture des jo de 2024
qui se déroulera sur la scène mais avant
de parler de ces thèmes on va parler
football et de la coupe de france
[Musique]
on va donc parler football et de la
coupe de france versailles qui évolue en
nationale 2 s'est qualifié pour les as
16e de finale de la coupe de france ce
samedi les joueurs de la cité royale se
sont imposés 1 but à 0 en terre
alsacienne face à sarre union le but a
été inscrit par djoko capitte en
première période on regarde cette
réaction dans le vestiaire
[Applaudissements]
mike ça fait plaisir à voir je nage bien
sûr monsieur renvoie encore une fois le
sport ce que ça transmet énormément de
joie d'énergie et c'était beau à voir et
puis en plus on a parlé la semaine
dernière de cette équipe de de
versailles qui a bien progressé ces
dernières années et là on voit encore
qui donne une bonne volonté de de
pouvoir vraiment faire quelque chose de
bon et en tout cas pour ma part je les
félicite et je tiens à dire aussi que
bon pour l'instant ils ont joué quand
des équipes vous était largement favori
oui là c'était contre ils sont en ligue
2 il jouait contre une national 3-1
sarre-union exactement exactement donc
pour l'instant ils font leur petit
bonhomme de chemin mais c'est à suivre
arnaud qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
cette qualification en 16e de finale que
celle de france c'est populaire on en
parlera que ça leur permet d'avancer
dans le tableau ça fait parler du club
ça permet à la population de les
découvrir ou de redécouvrir ça ça donne
donne envie tout simplement on a vu la
joie des joueurs mais au conseil de la
joie du public des supporters et moi je
pense toujours à ce cas au bout c'est à
dire des petits garçons des petites
filles qui du coup ont envie d'aller
faire du sport ont envie de rejoindre le
club local et et c'est ça le plus
important pierre chevallier alors vous
vous êtes fier forcément bon jette au
rugby-club de versailles mais vous
suivez avec un rendez vous on est
voisins que le football à tout ce qui
est bon pour le sport d'une manière
générale et d'une manière locale aussi à
versailles est bon c'est la magie la
magie de cette coupe de france
vous savez je suis un grand fan de
grands fans de l'épreuve même montant
que rugbyman mais grand fan de l'ex prof
de l'épreuve parce que justement il n'y
a qu'au foot il ya qu'en coupe de france
qu'on peut trouver des trajets comme
celui là alors si c'est vrai que pour
l'instant pour l'instant les oppositions
n'étaient pas forcément très très relevé
on s'attendait à ce qu'en 16e versailles
tombe sur un gros finalement ça va être
à nouveau une équipe de n3 j'ai une
permettait de vie tant qu'il n'y a pas
de souci et mais en tout cas cci
permettait de faire la transition très
très très très fier pour les verser
alors les versailles et affronteront
prochain tôt un autre club de national 3
à la roche sur yon objectif dépasser le
meilleur parcours de l'histoire du club
qui était un 16e de finale en quelle
date à votre avis messieurs
on écoute juste rôles le capitaine
électif
là je pense qu'avec le tirage ça reste à
ça reste un match abordable maintenant
on va bien préparer ce match on sait que
cette équipe de la revente est une très
bonne équipe qui est invaincue cette
année qui 12e avec un point de retard
avec deux matches en moins
donc on sait que ce sera pas facile et
de toutes les manières tous les matches
que nous avons fait jusqu'à présent en
coupe de france y en a aucun qui ait été
facile alors la rencontre soit programmé
le dimanche 2 janvier à
13h45 au stade mort en face à ce club de
nationale 3 la question sur ce thème est
ce que vous êtes un petit peu déçu quand
même par le tirage voter oui ou non oui
ou non voter non pour vous oui pour vous
arnaud enfin petit duel entre arnaud et
et mike alors oui oui vous êtes déçu
alors du coup non mais c'est pas
nécessairement déçu mais disons que je
pense que finalement comme l'ailé comme
les joueurs il aura envie de se frotter
à une grosse écurie voilà et qu' il
reste encore paris marseille mais mais
mais finalement alors c'est peut-être
l'opportunité de passer un tour de plus
même si on a vu que c'était loin d'être
gagné d'avancé un bien sûr mais on sait
très bien que rencontrer une grande
équipe ça à d'autres répercussions que
sportive médiatique voilà et pour les
joueurs c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire donc
ça aurait pu être tout de suite ce sera
peut-être je leur souhaite pour le match
d'après voilà le match n'est pas encore
gagné non mais en tout cas on leur
souhaite vivement manon pour ma part
c'est pour gagner la coupe de france et
les concours de circonstances donc
forcément je vous contre plusieurs
véhicules de plusieurs tableaux et puis
après force et moi si on joue des
meilleures équipes ça amène beaucoup
plus des affiches beaucoup plus de
médiatisation autour de ça mais voilà si
vous faut quand même faut pas faire la
fine bouche et prendre ce moment là et
puis il essaie de faire le mieux pour
qualifier cette équipe de versailles
pour le prochain tour pierre vous restez
sur notre position est homogène d'accord
avec micky plutôt d'accord avec mike
même si même si c'est là la magie de la
coupe de france ça viendra après les les
gros selon toute vraisemblance il passe
les 16e en huitièmes il risque de
prendre au moins une ligue 2 lidoli
garde évidemment plus c'est plus ça
serait plus ça se rapproche de la
nationale ça serait vraiment un gros
gros concours de circonstances et un
gros coup de add donc c'est bon pour le
coup c'est pas déçu parce que parce
qu'il faut de la chance il faut il faut
la provoquer aussi c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça et on va pas effectivement bout
d une étape
une étape abordable avec avec une m3 et
surtout aussi je reprends les terres
mais finalement le l'esprit du capitaine
et ce qui tourne autour de toute
l'équipe pour l'instant depuis le tirage
en a pas un qui s'emballe ils sont tous
à dire prudence le match n'est pas gagné
c'est ce que c'est quand même le cabinet
elle c'est la gorge en tirer plutôt des
petites équipes si je peux dire mais ils
n'ont jamais gagné 5 6 ou 7 000
militaires du rang 0 face à la télé il
va pas dire qu on joue contre une équipe
qui est faible et on va les sous-estimer
c'est ça va dans l'esprit du sport on va
forcément respecté des adversaires même
si peut-être à l'intérieur ils savent
très bien qu'ils sont capables de battre
cette équipe là donc oui on voit là il
ya aussi la pédagogie le 2-2 de
s'exprimer aussi de français et on
disait c'est peut-être ça sera peut-être
le record du club en coupe de france est
ce que ça joue aussi dans toutes les
têtes arnaud de battre ce record il leur
faut encore tour il faut gagner encore
un match pour propane sur le capot pour
les équipes pour le pour les joueurs
pour le staff ça joue forcément surtout
quand on sait qui date de 1940 8148 oui
ou non il altère son nom dans l'histoire
gueugnon 4 à 1 pour l'année histoire ben
voila voila on oublie donc au nom bien
sûr et puis on en seulement on a envie
que il bat sam et qui le bat nettement
et qu'ils inscrivent quelque chose de
neuf et de au palmarès très clairement
et bien sûr il est des clubs amateurs
ils doivent batailler quand même depuis
très longtemps pour arriver jusqu'à ne
serait-ce que 30 de vie 16e les gros l2
ligue 2 liant n'arrive qu'après donc un
huitième de finale s'il se dit c'est un
long parcours c'est déjà un très joli
parcours prend un club de nationale 2 le
match n'est pas gagné encore une fois
mais on retiendra en plus du record je
pense que ce qu'ils vont retenir c'est
une très belle aventure en coupe de
france qui peut peut-être même durée en
cours en corde autour soyons fou mais
c'est c'est en tout cas c'est en tout
cas 2,2 beau objectif aller chercher et
ça conforte aussi peut-être versailles
dans sa politique du moment où on sait
ils ont eu beaucoup d'argent qui avec
l'arrivée notamment par rapport à un
partenaire privé logiquement il devrait
monter l'année prochaine en nationale
une cette année ils sont en 16e de
finale voire plus ça les conforte dans
leur projet peut-être mike oui tout à
fait d'accord tout à fait d'accord on
sait que pour construire un club il faut
une bonne structuration à tous les
niveaux dont qui semble dans ce schéma
là donc il faut qu'ils continuent à
travailler dans ce sens et puis ce qu'on
leur souhaite aussi c'est de jouer des
grandes équipes pendant ce tour de
france à la permettra de aussi
d'apprendre des choses de voir ce qui se
fait de mieux et aussi ça apporte de
l'argent au club valaisan déjà gagné
environ 50 mille soixante mille euros en
étant réglé à ce stade de la compétition
que sportivement et financièrement
commencer une une saison changement de
dévolution parce qu'on en a déjà pas mal
parlé là c'est mieux de le faire avec 1
avec un joli tour en coupe de france
joli parcours en coupe de france dans
l'agression du pronostic autour de cette
table pas moins pas de pronostic
pierre moi j'aime ou j'aime je m'étais
je m'étais planté je m'étais planté d'un
but sur le 32e je vais dire 2-2 thouars
versailles de mike victoire 5-2 0.20 on
ressortira la vidéo après si besoin
alors on suivra cela avec attention la
rencontre de la coupe de france de coupe
de france ce sera donc le 2 janvier au
stade moreau de versailles bon courage
au versailles et on espère évidemment
une victoire alors toujours en football
on connaît désormais les affiches des
huitièmes de finale de la ligue des
champions c'est un cran plus loin que la
coupe de france le paris saint germain
affrontera le real madrid avec un match
aller au parc des princes le 15 février
et à un match retour le 9 mars à madrid
les deux équipes sont assez proches
l'une de l'autre sur le papier les
bookmakers anglais donne un léger
avantage au real sur cette double
confrontation
la question qui est favori sur cette
confrontation qui sera qualifiée en cas
où tu es
le paris saint germain
le paris saint germain je suis rassuré
de ce que disent les bookmakers anglais
comme ça on pourra les faire mentir et
pas jouer un peu avec 10 50 ans un peu
et là aussi c'est une histoire c'est une
construction 1
les histoires sont longues sur ces deux
équipes mais le paris saint germain se
donne les moyens de progresser le pape a
parlé de l'effectif qui est
extraordinaire il faut y croire y'a pas
de raison je pense qu'ils ont tous une
envie incroyable de
de réussir vous n'êtes pas un peu mitigé
sur le début de campagne de ligue des
champions de paris non ça ça me
rassurerait presque même je préfère que
ça parte tout ce bon ça arrive fort
plutôt que l'inversé mike pas ce que
vous en pensez alors pour vous qui est
favori moi je fais un peu mitigé pour la
simple raison que l'on sait que en
général les matchs où les compétitions
ça ça change beaucoup en ce moment si on
regarde études de paris on peut pas les
mettre favoris parce que qu'on voit le
ski proposent par rapport à leurs yeux
une équipe qui est divisée en deux que
ce soit des défenseurs les milieux de
terrain et les attaquants et ça s'est vu
pendant la ligue des champions est par
contre une équipe de rennes a démarré
avec un benzema qui est vraiment le
tollé de cette équipe là qui contrôle
bien le jeu et une équipe qui est bien
construit qui est équilibré à tous les
niveaux on a envie de dire c'est
compliqué pour paris mais maintenant je
suis je suis français je supporte paris
je suis à paris donc on voit là on
aimerait que paris puisse gagner mais
ils ont du travail à faire pendant
pendant la trêve et pendant les deux
mois qui restent devant le paris dans
cette ligue des champions trois
victoires avec notamment une victoire
contre manchester city on s'en souvient
tous avec ce but de messi deux nuls et
une défaite que ce que vous en pensez
mike
à l'image de à l'image de
farine en ligue des champions c'est sûr
mais après ce qui ce qui est difficile à
avoir quand même c'est qu'il n'y a pas
une progression on voit que pochettino
il a du mal à installer son système de
jeu parce que c'est quand même un
entraîneur qui a l'habitude d'avoir une
équipe qui presse qui joue on est là
avec les caractéristiques des joueurs de
paris avec un messi qui il faut dire la
vérité qui a pas l'habitude de presser
c'est pas son style de jeu l'équipe qui
a un peu j'ai l'impression on ne peu
handicapé ou mal construites et donc du
coup ça s'appelle un peu mais mais voilà
après mais s'est aggravée marquée 5,5
fois en ligue des champions un seul but
en ligue 1 les cinq fois en ligue des
champions oui bien sûr il a été
il a été il était décisive mais
maintenant on va jouer des matches qui
se déprécie pour ça qu'il n'y a pas
tellement
pour moi
[Musique]
je vais aller un petit peu contre contre
l'esprit chant et en disant que par
contexte et par compétences c'est le
real qui a une courte tête de favori le
real juste pour quelques chiffres cinq
victoires pour une seule défaite en
ligue des champions à cette année
premier touriste de la liga avec cinq
points d'avancé sur séville actuellement
à un plus tout le reste et comme disait
micheal il ya une expérience collective
qui fait qu'en plus la plupart des
joueurs sont là depuis quelque temps ce
qui n'est pas le cas de paris on a du
mal à trouver le ciment de cette équipée
et que ça coulisses de derrière à
l'avant en passant par des milieux qui
sont très à l'image de vera titre est
irrégulier et très irrégulièrement
justement aligner parce que blessure
parce que parce que plein de plein de
raisons diverses et variées donc en
termes de en termes de compétences on a
des retrouvailles d'entraîneurs aussi
qu'ils connaissent bien paris mais
pochettino a moins d'expérience que
l'entraîneur du real et on a on a on a
surtout des joueurs qui sont qui sont
habitués aux joutes européennes et
notamment les des champions qui performe
à l'année dernière près qu'ils
performent en ligue 1 et et qui sont
organisés autour d'une distribution de
ballons avec un verre à benzema qui
était en feu cette année et qui met
quasiment tout ce qui est tout ce qui
tente derrière on a une équipe de paris
qui qui peine à trouver justement cette
alchimie entre ces différentes stars
messi a réalisé ce pourquoi il était
venu en ligue des champions c'est à dire
on qualifier qualifié paris pour les
huitièmes ça c'est fait quand même dans
la douleur malgré tout on a un et
marquez qui est régulier et on a on à
kiki et m'appellent acquis en revanche
dit tient la baraque devant mais pour
l'instant et qui pourrait signer au real
madrid et en voilà c'est là où je
voulais en venir c'est cette histoire de
contexte qui fait que ça sera
particulière pour une bonne vieille
terre c'est particulier ça sera
particulier pour les deux équipes parce
que ils sont tous au courant et que
grosso modo avant même avant la fin
avant la fin de la saison on pourrait
savoir que qu'elle bat p pars pars au
real ça va être je pense que c'est
malgré son jeune âge c'est déjà un grand
champion il ya un sportif aguerri vu ce
qu'il réalise en ce moment cette saison
avec paris malgré tout ça va quand même
être assez particulier à gérer dans la
tête sur ces deux matches aller retour
il ya eu aussi cette imbroglio autour du
tirage au sort il ya eu un problème dans
l'attribution des fameuses boules alors
le psg il devait affronter manchester
united
mais s'il devait retrouver ronaldo ça
aurait été peut-être un meilleur tirage
selon vos arnaud
c'est une question compliquée
le tirage est ce qu'il est et c'est
comme la décision de l'arbitré ne voit
qu'elle est prise elle est prise donc
voilà
c'est comme ça et c'est le real et c'est
pas quelqu'un d'autre mike moi je
pourrais pas la commenter après ce qui
était bizarre c'est de voir tout ce qui
s'est passé oui et ça c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment bizarre ça où chaque ou
pas ce qui s'est passé sur le terrain
quand même parce que ce moment là il ya
le monde entier qui regarde ce qui se
passe et
ils ont fait quand même quelque chose
qui est qui rarissime quand même c'est
ça nous a vraiment choqué à ce niveau-là
il assez assez assez différence donc là
c'est ces enjeux là c'est complètement
quand on quand on regarde les images
même même les ceux qui sont au tirage
contre ils comprennent pas il ya des
rires gênés des sourires un petit peu
embarrassé et puis hop on arrête tout on
recommence
puis on a eu plusieurs des erreurs de
fait de placements bull comme ça dans
les dents les chapeaux
c'est incompréhensible incompréhensive à
ce niveau là de là à dire que tiré
manchester aurait été il est éveillé
l'enjeu suis parce que je suis pas sûr
que ça aurait été un meilleur tirage
nantes saison ça pouvait pas se ça ne
pouvait pas se trouver mais
bon ça se joue à partir des huitièmes de
finale de ligue des champions tiens peut
il ya peu de temps car on va passer
notre thématique suivante on souhaite
bon courage aux parisiens pour cette
rencontre on aura sûrement l'occasion
d'en reparler sur tv 78 d'ici à courant
février on passe maintenant notre page
débats
[Musique]
en ce mois de décembre les organisateurs
des jeux de paris 2024 ont levé le voile
sur la cérémonie d'ouverture et pour la
première fois de l'histoire des jeux
olympiques modernes la cérémonie se
déroulera non pas dans un stade mais en
pleine ville les 10500 aux athlètes
entraîneurs et autres membres des 206
délégation embarqueront du pont
d'austerlitz puis descendront la scène
sur 160 barre jusqu'au pont d'iéna les
concepteurs du spectacle utiliseront les
ponts qui enjambent la scène plus de six
cent mille spectateurs sont attendus sur
les berges de seine ce sera le 26
juillet 2024 la question sur ce thème la
cérémonie d'ouverture cette cérémonie
d'ouverture soit elle la plus grandiose
de l'histoire selon vous oui ou non
weebly de oui oui
vous êtes une alim nani grandiose jeux
mondiaux alors le courtier qu'est ce que
vous en pensez alors la plus belle
cérémonie de l'histoire des jeux
probablement parce que j'ai des idées
très belle quand même mais la plus
populaire le plus grand nombre de
spectateurs dans la plus belle ville du
monde vous voulez quoi d'autre sur l'axé
central de paris qui est la scène qui
coupe parfaitement la ville en deux qui
va la cérémonie qui va réunir finit
finalement les deux rives qui donne
l'opportunité à n'importe quel
spectateur d'assister à ça normalement
c'est dans un stade et un nombre de
places compter point final tout le monde
devant sa télé là ça va être
extraordinaire extraordinaire pour les
spectateurs extraordinaire pour les
athlètes aussi qu'ils vont vivre un
moment absolument
unique dans une carrière j'espère que ça
donnera des idées à l'avenir aussi pour
l'épauler les futures villes qui
accueilleront les jeux olympiques ça
peut créer un précédent
ça va forcément créer un précédent parce
que il ya toujours un petit challenge
une volonté de faire mieux de faire
différent tout cas d'être original je
vois mal comment
au jeu suivant il pourrait faire une
cérémonie dans un stade
classique finalement ça paraît difficile
alors il faut pas non plus trop de
surenchère parce que après il ya des
problématiques humaines financières
logistiques et ses mails à paris se
prête merveilleusement à ça los angeles
si on veut comparer une mégapole
s'étaler c'est on ne peut pas faire ça à
paris c'est absolument idéal on n'aurait
pas pu faire ça à londres la ville ne
s'y prêtait pas de la même manière paris
se prête merveilleusement à ça je suis
extrêmement reconnaissant aux
organisateurs des jeux de paris 2024
d'avoir eu cette idée de se donner les
moyens de la mettre en oeuvre et
d'offrir ce spectacle au parisien aux
français et au monde entier finalement
vous avez pu discuter un petit peu avec
les personnes qui ont pris cette
décision n'ont pas encore assez bon
score mais mais j'attends de les voir
avec impatience pour de leur dire juste
bravo merci
une péniche peut-être je sais pas où je
serai mais je serai dans le coin vous
pouvez compter sur moi mike qu'est ce
que vous en pensez alors vous êtes
pareils conquis oui monsieur après pour
pas répéter pour pas répéter mais
simplement pour compléter ce que vous
avez dit pour mais à deux choses qui est
important c'est simplement
on voit que le sport évolue avec la
société et là il ya une volonté vraiment
politique comme je dis toujours de
l'oligarchie de vouloir mettre le sport
à un niveau différent et là c'est
spectaculaire parce que ça avance avec
notre époque et on le voit dans
l'histoire des olympiques c'est à chaque
foyer une évolution il ya des
changements qui se font à chaque fois et
donc là encore c'est une belle preuve et
puis après la deuxième chose c'est cette
volonté de communes et les spectateurs
avec des athlètes moi je trouve que
c'est spectaculaire mais qu'est ce que
ça change que ce soit pierre sur la
scène et pas dans un stade qu'est ce que
ça change concrètement je pense qu'on
peut insister sur un interne qui est
celui de l'ouverture dire que là en
l'occurrence on sort d'une enceinte
fermée stade compter lee ite en termes
de nombre de spectateurs à une structure
complètement ouverte et en plus avec une
pour ma part je pense une formidable
synthèse de la culture celle de paris
tellement de l'histoire cent ans après
le 100 ans après les derniers jours en
france
et et de l'esprit populaire
effectivement d'ouverture complet de ces
jeux qui vont être gardés par des
milliards de téléspectateurs et qui en
plus sur le territoire français vont
permettre à dix fois plus de spectateurs
quasiment 10 ou 15 fois plus de
spectateurs vraiment physique
n'assistait
le à peu près parce qu'il ya
contribué c'est à dire qu'il ya un loup
soit disant km il ya un doux dingue
thierry reboul qui est à la tête de de
ski et de des événements et de la marque
géniaux et qui a imaginé 7 7 cette
cérémonie mais il faut être doux dingues
justement pour pour l'imaginer mais quel
pied c'est à dire que là en plus si on
se place si on essaye de se placer du
point de vue des athlètes on va
prolonger le plaisir à dire que d'un
petit tour de stade qui doit déjà être
magique pour la plupart des athlètes qui
ont connu ça soit aux jo d'hiver aux jo
d'été avec les petits drapeaux et faire
coucou à tout le monde représenter son
pays c'est déjà magique mais là la dent
dans la plus belle ville du monde là
soyons chauvins avec avec cette
ouverture ce nombre de spectateurs et
pour le coup un spectacle qui promet
d'être absolument grandiose
on est en fait le pied intégral c'est de
se dire qu'on va faire partie de tout ça
chacun à notre niveau notre niveau et on
va pouvoir prendre part à ça et on a
plus de chance de le faire sur une
cérémonie ouverte avec 610 personnes qui
avec avait que 60 milles dans un stade
mais apparemment pour l'instant ce n'est
pas encore sûr et certain mais ça
devrait être gratuit également à part
certains emplacements près des ponts
notamment ce aussi une bonne une bonne
mesure on pourra cesser à ces trois
heures trente de spectacle gratuitement
durant sur quelques remplacements répit
mais oui mais oui mais sept buts et le
sport à la portée de tous c'est ce qui
m'est revenue dans l'évolution du sport
ce que tu disais de plus en plus le
sport est au service de lui même
longtemps le sport est un outil
propagande pour diverses causes
aujourd'hui le sport fait la propagande
du sport dès là c'est pas mal je trouve
et puis là on le met au coeur de la
ville on ne mesure pas il faudra du
temps pour mesurer l'impact corps à
cette cérémonie dans les années qui vont
suivre en développement économique en
tourisme sur paul pour paris pour la
france fin c'est une image tuer des
milliards de spectateurs vont voir ça
c'est c'est fantastique c'est le plus
bel hommage qu'on puisse faire à pierre
de coubertin voilà cent trente ans après
on est là et les jeux au coeur de la
ville et c'est oui pour les athlètes ça
va être fabuleux pour les ordinateurs ça
va être extraordinaire pour le public ça
va être fantastique pour les forces de
l'ordre ça va être un petit peu
compliqué parce qu'il va y avoir deux
trois souci de sécurisation mais à part
ça
il faut espérer une belle météo
également oui il faut espérer
ne le maîtrise pas savoir le 26 juillet
quelques temps et froome et 2024 bien on
attend tout cas on a tous les éléments
pour une fête vraiment extraordinaire
hors du commun n'y a pas de mots je
dirais je sais c'est pas dire envie de
le dire ça va être fabuleux et tous les
quatre ans on mettait on mettait un
stade olympique au milieu milieu du
dispositif et c'était ce qui était
diffusé dans le monde entier et pour les
spectateurs qui avaient la chance d'y
assister là on promeut occasion
peut-être quatre où cinq sites
olympiques ont de plus si si si on
regarde un petit peu le trocadéro et
après les différentes je pense ça va ça
va être aussi ça va être diffusé sur des
écrans les autres sites en appui de
mellala en gros c'est une ville
olympique compromis un compromis et
environ 80 un écran un type installé
partout sur le marco rossi pour que tous
en profiter et notamment les spectateurs
plus les athlètes je disais tout à
l'heure le prolonger le plaisir mais
descendre la scène sur des barges
d'austerlitz jusque jusqu'au jusqu'au
bout jusqu'au trocao champ-de-mars cc
c'est là aussi ça doit être magique déjà
participe au giro marc après bourse dans
ce type d'événement encore plus dingue
magic mike mokongo alors qu'est ce que
est ce que ça vous surprend ou pas quoi
que ce soit aussi novateur ces jeux de
paris avec cet homme d'ouverture est ce
que ça vous surprendre la part de
l'organisation parisienne vous
finalement ça coule de source quand on
entend les distinctions prend lui et non
parce que on est dans un monde où tout
est analysé tout est vraiment
regarde au millimètre près donc je pense
que toutes ces personnes qui organisent
les jeux ils échangent pas mal entre eux
donc après il ya une volonté collective
de vouloir faire ça donc non je pense
pas du tout et de marquer peut-être
l'histoire peut-être des jeux olympiques
aussi on a l'impression que sur ces jeux
de 2024 je sais pas à 51 amis comment ça
se passe dans l'impression qu'on veut
marquer ces jeux olympiques ils sont
peut-être unique dans une vie ils seront
définitivement unis dans une vie en tout
cas dans la nôtre
on le répète ok on les avait on les a
eues il ya cent ans on les a maintenant
on sait pas quand est-ce qu'on les aura
de nouveau mais probablement pas avant
très longtemps donc c'est une
opportunité à saisir une fois encore
parce que le sport c'est merveilleux et
que doit ça finalement à la population
et particulièrement aux jeunes
générations mais qui se sont hélas je
peux parler pour saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est un coup de projecteur
extraordinaire donc c'est du ce et du
rayonnement du territoire c'est du
développement économique c'est du
tourisme c'est d'éducation c'est
beaucoup de choses donc c'est la chance
de se saisir de cet événement qui est un
moteur pour des tas d'autres sujets qui
nous permettent d'avancer beaucoup plus
vite et donc de faire le bien à des tas
de niveaux avec un catalyseur qui est le
sport qui est qui le plus beau des
sujets parce que le sport ça concerne
tout le monde c'est bon pour la santé
c'est bon pour la tête il faut que tout
le monde fasse du sport on sait que les
problèmes de santé existent dans toutes
les sociétés et particulièrement dans
les sociétés dites civilisées
donc il faut qu'une prise de conscience
et donc les jeux c'est un accélérateur
sur tous ces sujets et qui va doivent et
qu'ils vont faire un bien fou à notre
pays que ce soit à saint quentin en
yvelines bien sûr mais partout ailleurs
en tout cas on a hâte d'être à ce 26
juillet 2024 pour voir cette magnifique
cérémonie d'ouverture on l'aura compris
on sera tous là on ne sait pas où un
peut-être au niveau de la flamme pour
vous un pierre chevallier je sais que
vous allez poujade a porté la flamme
pour bon sur la dernière ligne droite
alors on va maintenant passer à un autre
envolée du jour grégory canal et vous
l'aurez remarqué n'est pas avec nous sur
ce plateau il est en vacances et oui il
y en a qui ont de la chance il nous a
enregistré son envolée à distance
aujourd'hui nous a dit qu'ils étaient
sont divines watts de l'année à 2021 on
regarde sa vidéo salue la team quelle
année sportive encore malgré la crise
sanitaire les athlètes yvelinois nous
ont une nouvelle fois époustouflé alors
qui est le sportif yvelinois de l'année
louis burton sa troisième place au
vendée globe nous a fait rentrer de la
plus belle des manières dans cette
nouvelle année où il a dû abandonner sur
la transat en novembre mais leur embolie
temps fait partie désormais des tous
meilleurs skippers mondiaux pourquoi pas
emilie boulard l inscrire le plus bel
essai féminin de l'année selon world
rugby inscrits contre le pays de galles
lors de sa première sélection en avril
rien que ça l'arrière de 21 ans habitant
de la celle les bordes collectionne six
capes en bleu la jeunesse au pouvoir
avec victor webb anyama 17 ans de m 19
et déjà beaucoup d'observateurs de nba
le basketteur formé à l'entente le
chesnay versailles pourrait être drafté
en 2023 il a plongé dans le grand bain
cette saison en passant de nanterre à
l'asvel le club de tony parker
le joueur est sélectionné pour le all
star game de la bête cliquez vite 2021
année olympique et oui avec sa
coéquipière laura taranto la claire
beauvais 23 ans a décroché l'argent aux
jo en aviron première médaille en 40 ans
pour son club l'association sportive
mantaise je vous propose aussi maiva
hamadouche elle était candidate pour
être notre porte drapeau aux jeux de
tokyo est la boxeuse de la team farrugia
n'est pas passé loin non plus de réunir
les deux ceintures mondiales ipf et wb
au début novembre c'est une championne
en dehors des rings la policière est
engagée auprès des femmes victimes de
violence conjugale et alex portal le
nageur de saint germain en laye a porté
haut les couleurs de la france aux jeux
paralympiques une médaille d'argent et
une médaille de bronze pour ses débuts
dans la compétition
à 19 ans tous les espoirs sont permis
pour paris ii 24 antoine ros nre lui
avait très bien démarré 2021 victoire au
qatar masters succès contre l'un des
meilleurs au monde bryson de chambaud en
match play le pensionnaire du golf de la
boulie à versailles a participé à deux
tournois du grand chelem avec moins de
réussite sur la fin de saison mais moi
j'ai fait mon choix mon sportif
yvelinois de l'année c'est arthur à
rinderknecht une progression fulgurante
au delà de la 170e place en janvier le
saint germanois est aujourd'hui le 58e
tennisman mondial le joueur de 26 ans a
remporté le tournoi challenger
d'istanbul battu deux top 20 mondiaux
cerise sur le gâteau sa participation à
la coupe davis avec l'équipe de france
énorme quand on sait qu'il est arrivé
tard sur le circuit en 2018 alors
messieurs d'accord avec moi pas du tout
j'ai hâte d'entendre vos avis je vous
dis à très vite et très bonnes fêtes de
fin d'année je vous laisse répondre à
grégory est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec lui arthur unops nash numéro un il
dit noah sportif évinois l'année 2021
pierre pas complètement pas complètement
pas complètement je
met en jeu mais en compétition de sport
individuel même si arthur a joué en
équipe en coupe davis mais je levais je
le met en compétition avec antoine roth
nerfs
dans la difficulté que ces deux percées
dans le golf professionnel versus aussi
tennis professionnel on a on a deux
sports qui sont dans lequel il est
difficile de briller alors c'est vrai
que là la progression d'arthur
rinderknecht est assez notable ça pour
le coup et les mathématiques mais je
mets
ça c'est le golfeur qui parle je mets
une pièce sur antoine
pour ses résultats de début de saison
malheureusement elle aurait pu ne pas
souffrir aux coulisses et finalement ça
a fait reculer le choc et
moi je connais ce en connaissant la
difficulté à mon modeste niveau de golf
la difficulté de ce sport je mets une
pièce sur antoine avec ses sa victoire
en championnat du monde de match-play
contre brayson de chambaud et puis son
sa victoire au qatar dans sur le tour
européen il faut stéphane et ses
tournois là pour gagner et briller et je
suis sûr que je suis sûr que la fin de
saison somme toute un peu moins réussie
pour ne pas dire raté par rapport à son
début va lui servir à rebondir et à
revenir mais moi je dis entonneront ce
n'est par le courtier ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec
avec pierre avec grégory
golfeur de coeur
oui alors d'abord ce qui est génial
c'est d'avoir le choix entre temps de
sportive
il faut dire
ces deux super banane et on a des grands
talents ça c'est merveilleux oui pierre
leleux
le golf est pas un sport très culturelle
en france et peu de gens connaissent la
réalité du circuit c'est très très dur
c'est vraiment très dur et faire ce
qu'il a fait c'est magnifique on espère
effectivement que cette fin de saison va
lui servir mais c'est en fait c'est tout
à fait logique ça va lui servir pour
continuer à avancer
battre reason de chango voilà le mal
c'était extraordinaire
parce que j'aime le golfe
antoine austère mais mais toutes les
performances un préfet puisse parler
comme vous le disait d'arthur
rinderknecht qui est aux portes du top
50 mondial que antoine runner finalement
mais parce que on parle plus de tennis
ou de golf en france voilà tout
simplement mais attention c'est pareil à
être au top du porte cinq ans aux portes
du top 50 j allais mondiale en tennis
c'est aussi monstrueux c'est enfin c'est
une difficulté énorme c'est un travail
incroyable les gens oublient souvent que
sportif de haut niveau c'est un métier à
temps plein qui est inquiète un
sacerdoce qui demande un entraînement
incroyable on voit souvent c'est les
grands champions les paillettes quand on
est arrivé mais pour y arriver le
travail est dingue et pour se maintenir
il est encore plus dingue la concurrence
est énorme on est d'accord voilà c'est à
vous mme alquier alors qui est qui pour
vous le sportif évinois de l'année
arthur et 9,9 antoine ros nord il y en a
eu d'autres il va hamadouche claire bové
qui a réussi une superbe médaille
d'argent aux jo c'est peut-être c'est
très con fait plus parler peut-être
moins n'ont même pas j'ai peut-être que
ça va vous choquer ce que je veux dire
mais pour ma part c c'est difficile de
répondre à cette question d'un pour la
simple raison que tous ses athlètes là
ils ont marqué leur discipline cette
année là ils ont tous tout le monde a
évolué tout le monde a progressé et
c'est difficile de dire qu'un athlète à
réaliser mieux que tout le monde parce
que en fin de compte ça serait
décrédibiliser les autres sa dette par
rapport à ce qu'ils ont fait par rapport
à leur travail par rapport à ce qu'ils
ont effectué toute la saison donc il
faut bien un mais comme le disait paul
c'est quoi la sélection ces tags et
c'est quoi c'est quoi le juge de paix
alors par rapport à sa série canale
[Rires]
c'est diviser choisis sur des toits ce
qui se passait beaucoup plus simple
c'est beaucoup plus simple si c'est tout
c'est à tes deux là sont ils ont ils
sont dans la même discipline mais la cdi
ping qui sont complètement différentes
et et voilà après je suis basketteur
j'irai victoria et
magna va d'ailleurs qu'il ne participera
pas au all-star game sébastien si vous
avez vu maille qui s'est blessé oui ces
blessés dans la pire encore
qu'un jour physique mais ce que victor
n'est pas trop jeune là pour l'instant
on l'a dit il va il va avoir 18 ans
parce qu'il n'est pas trop jeune pour
être encore le sportif illinois l'aller
je sais pas si en matière de sport on
peut définir ça comme ça parce que
quelques heures par exemple à 18 ans il
était déjà nba avait un temps la ghana
titre nba donc chez c'est ton talent qui
parle du fait donc n'y a pas d'âge y'a
pas d'âge mais après c'est dommage pour
lui de encore une fois se blesser parce
qu'il n'arrive pas à vraiment progressé
continuez sur 156 moi aussi on l'a pas
trop évoquer louis burton qui a fini
troisième du vendée globe ce n'était pas
forcément attendu louis burton qui a
raté sa transat jacques vabre qui a
abandonné au bout de même pas 24 heures
de course louis burton aussi super
performance
sur 7 sur ce vendée globe
2020 2021 encore une discipline
incroyable hélas hélas c'est dans la
tête quoi c'est la capacité
des skippers c'est quelque chose
d'admirable je pense qu'on ne peut pas
imaginer ce que c'est de vivre ce qu'ils
vivent en même temps de procéder mes
souvenirs sont bons pendant quasiment
une semaine ils n'avaient pas de quoi
faire réchauffer ses plats il avait
quasiment pas d'eau pour boire sur leur
semaine de course et c'est ça l'idée
c'est que ça se termine salut d aventure
humaine incroyable qui doivent les
amener à avoir une réflexion sur eux
mêmes sur la vie absolument folle je
suis pas sûr que j'aurais envie de vivre
ça je suis sûr que je n'en serais pas
capable
voilà et donc donc on ne peut être
qu'admiratif ça c'est certain oui oui
bertone
qui est extrêmement extrêmement
exigeante on a parlé sont aussi des
conditions de course de débarras de
départ les pénalités et puis et puis les
avaries en plus ici même le meilleur le
meilleur des navigateurs dépend des pans
de dépendre son bateau donc les autres
athlètes
l'aspect matériel est un plan tout petit
peu moins important mais on l'a un
skipper c'est c'est dans la tête c'est
facteur chance aussi et puis et puis la
maîtrise de son bateau il ya aussi des
des paramètres techniques qu'il faut
qu'on en compte mais oui oui belle
performance aussi c'est sûr alors
maintenant passé à l'équipe de l'année
plusieurs équipes ont performé en 2021
là on a retenu quatre pour que pierre
soit encore avec nous l'année prochaine
sur ce un plateau on a nominé le
rugby-club de versailles qui est
invaincu dans le championnat de fédérale
3 et qui a une très belle équipe pour
monter on a également nominé versailles
football qui est deuxième du championnat
de nationale 2 qui jouera en 1 16e de
finale de coupe de france et peut-être
plus l'année prochaine alors il ya
également sans la bretèche son golf qui
a remporté là golfeurs se 2021 face à
toulouse avec une brillante charlotte
liothier une victoire surprenante acquis
sur les terres du golf de saint jean les
19 ans après son dernier sacre dans ce
championnat de france amateur d'armes de
première devise son nom la bretèche a
brillé et enfin poissy triathlon 3
sportif du club dans coninx cassante
beaugrand et léonie perriot ont remporté
une belle médaille de bronze à tokyo cet
été sur le relais mixte quelle est
l'équipe lilloise de l'année selon voté
par devinez
vous pouvez dire une autre équipe a pris
hier un personne s'éveille c'est vrai
qu'il ya dilemme parce que ça les i en
sortant en sortant du chapeau l'équipe
féminine de saint nom la bretèche au
golf pour avoir suivi la finale de la
gold force à saint germain contre
toulouse c'était un très beau match
alors après pas forcément plus et pas
forcément besoin d'être ultra
connaisseur pour regarder regardez tous
oui mais pour regarder une petite partie
c'était assez spectaculaire noste du
match plein et il cède donc les le golf
par équipes c'est juste c'est très
spectaculaire très télégénique aussi
donc là c'était sur les réseaux sociaux
d'éducation aussi ces compétitions qui a
de la valeur et carrément la valeur
historique mais bon passé ce dilemme là
évidemment je choisis je choisis le
coeur et le rugby-club versailles bien
évidemment pour une fois contre 22 qui
montera en 2020 allez on se mouille ça
fait déjà quelques temps qu'on le conte
l'annoncent c'est l'année où jamais pour
l'instant tous les compteurs sont au
vert tous les voyants les voyants sont
au vert il n'y a pas de confinement ou
hot normalement ça devrait
effectivement ça avait commencé comme ça
en 2019 et en 2019 2020 mais mais voilà
dont les sur des très très bons rails
alors le courtier alors d'abord juste
pour
vous êtes partagés
difficile mais le golfe ce qui est
intéressant c'est effectivement de voir
comment ce sport par essence individuels
et magique en équipe
on est le
le sommet mais oui c'est vraiment super
et ce qui a été cette victoire est
magnifique néanmoins et sur un beau
parcours sincèrement les mois je suis
obligé de répondre le coeur aussi poissy
triathlon club magnifique des athlètes
qui performent qui sont fabuleux une
infrastructure derrière tout ça pour les
performances n'arrive pas par hasard on
peut avoir les bons joueurs dans une
équipe des bons athlètes et c'est le
sport d'équipé va même au delà de
l'équipe celle qu'on voit même si le
sportif individuel n'est jamais seul non
plus le sport c'est un esprit d'équipé
il faut tout le monde soit là au bon
moment dans la préparation et c'est
chaque personne dans le staff a son rôle
et si les athlètes performent c'est
parce que tout s'est bien passé et le
club de triathlon de poissy bas fabuleux
fantastique voilà j'en profite des
meilleurs clubs on peut le dire moi je
dis de le meilleur que le maire
absolument donc voici bien sûr mike non
après moi j'ai pas honnêtement j'ai pas
tout suivi à 100% mais si je devais
choisir je dirais versailles car sa
photo rugby attention
si besoin était si nous on était d'avoir
quelques arguments supplémentaires
versailles versailles en rugby c'est
c'est la meilleure équipe de fédérale 3
au niveau national en terme de nombre
des ses marques et donc non seulement ça
gagne mais en plus ça joue ça joue au
rugby pour avoir suivi tous les matches
je sais que ça envoie ça envoie du game
huit matches huit victoires et la
deuxième équipe au niveau national en
fédérale 3 au niveau des points marqués
donc derrière les ongles qui est une
équipe l'équipe du sud-ouest donc
on a rarement atteint ses niveaux
historiques de performance avec les
seniors à versailles j'ajoute aussi que
l'équipe avait donc avec un petit peu
moins de budget que versailles foot un
second souffle
je confirme et donc l'équipe réserve
aussi est première de sa poule également
avec une seule défaite au compteur et on
a vraiment un groupe senior halak est
hyper attachant avec un staff qui se
démène on a on a un beau projet tous
ensemble avec les bénévoles avec les
dirigeants le staff tous les encadrants
on a une école de rugby nombreuses avec
près de 260 inscrits à l'école de rugby
cette année après deux années de
qu'ovide donc ça pousse derrière et
devant on est très content mike que vous
êtes convaincu pas encore bien sûr
non plus aux nuits et faute sur le même
pied d'égalité
on va maintenant passer à notre page
découverte la dernière partie de
l'émission
[Musique]
dans cette dernière partie des missions
je vous propose de terminer en beauté
avec une belle histoire celle de george
à 4 ans il est l'un des plus jeunes
licenciés à du département regardez son
portrait ce qu'est ce qui t'a prend à
jouer au golf
a pas une passion de père en fils à 4
ans seulement georges est le plus jeune
licencié du golfe isabella de plaisir
une histoire avec les clubs qui a débuté
il ya presque deux ans ça faisait un an
fin un peu moins d'un an et six mois
qu'il avait démarré et donc il ya eu
cette période de co vide où on était
tous à la maison et là bas pendant les
après midi lorsqu'on était enfermé bas
j'ai sorti un club est vraiment j'ai
remarqué que george a été très attiré il
tapait avec moi pratiquement tous les
midis un petit des balles pour faire des
petites approche pour françois son père
georges a déjà les qualités pour faire
de lui un futur bon golfeur et ce même
en temps de pluie je trouve qu'il est il
reste très concentré parce qu'ils
apprécient vraiment ça ils sont
objectifs et quand il tape une balle
c'est nous montrer qu' il a réussi donc
les très fier lorsqu'il a réussi à taper
la balle et après vraiment essayé de la
rentrée jusque dans le trou et il reste
très patient donc ça s'est vraiment bien
et c'est aussi autre chose c'est que
quand il rate un coup il arrive à se
reconcentrer dire c'est pas grave
je vais réessayer une deuxième fois tous
les dimanches l'apprenti golfeur vient
sur le domaine de plaisir soit pour
jouer avec sa famille soit pour
renforcer ses bases lors d'un cours de
45 minutes georges a été a été licencié
l'année de ses deux ans a au cours de sa
deuxième année là il a démarré à deux
ans et demi et et on a grand plaisir à
le compter parmi nos effectifs c'est
effectivement notre plus jeune pousse et
ça prouve à tout le monde qu'il n'ya pas
ya vraiment pas de limite pour que pour
commencer le goal
contrairement à d'autres enfants du club
il a il a moins déjà besoin de ses
parents pour aller tout de suite en
cours en fait il est il espère motiver
il pas trop timide georges a déjà passé
son premier drapeau en cours et
lorsqu'on lui demande il se voit
poursuivre sa passion pour toute la vie
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ce
petit georges quatre ans arnaud respect
et admiration
c'est mon plus grand regret c'est de ne
pas avoir découvert le golf à cet âge là
peut-être que ça m'aurait donné
l'opportunité d'être un meilleur joueur
que je vais me le suis je crois non mais
c'est super golf en l'occurrence on aime
ça mais ça n'importe quel sport des
enfants qui se passionnent pour un sport
du plus jeune âge c'est fabuleux parce
qu'on sait que ça va les aider à se
construire c'est ça reste la meilleure
école de la vie voilà et donc des jeunes
golfeurs c'est super c'est des futurs
champions on a besoin en france de papa
disait qu'il était concentré à
l'interview pas trop hein par contre
c'est parce qu'on sait si on faire un
tournage sur le au practice à taper des
balles on a priori il est concentré
effectivement quand on lui demande de
rester figé avec son papa devant la
caméra c'était la plus difficile mais
c'est une d une des preuves si besoin
était au delà de
de l'amour que j'ai pour le golf c'est
peut-être le seul sport qui peut se
jouer très tôt dans la vie est très tard
dans la vie on peut commencer à deux ans
et demi pour ce pour ce petit et puis
prat même si m tard ça donne quand même
quelques résultats malgré tout et il
jouait il jouer à deux en famille
père-fils grand père grand père petit
fils pendant des années et des années je
ne connais pas d'autres sports a priori
qui permet qui permet cette amplitude de
pratiques et de plaisir de plaisir
vraiment plaisir comme le comme le golf
isabella de mon copain hughes qui a vu
il ya vu naître aux gueules ce petit
georges mais c'est des histoires comme
ça il y en a dans beaucoup d'écoles de
golf en france et si cette année le golf
a explosé son record en terme de nombre
de licences c'est grâce à ces petits là
parce qu'il ya il ya quarante je croise
47 mille nouveaux golfeurs et parmi eux
je pense qu'il ya des classes d'âge qui
sont assez à ces jeunes parce que ce que
justement ils ont été ils ont été piqués
piqué au vif ça a été un des rares
sports qu'on pouvait pratiquer pendant
les périodes de déconfinement donc c'est
celle de c1 c'est un sport qui a le vent
en poupe là maintenant et ça donne ce
que ce type d'histoires très très
attachante et on espère des tonnes et
des tonnes an plus deux ans et demi on
apprend le golfe on peut vraiment la
prendre on peut la prendre c'est là je
pense qu'à un garçon comme celui là il y
là il a un geste naturel qui se met en
place alors évidemment évidemment
perspective perfectible à deux ans et
demi trois ans quatre ans oui vous avez
encore la ryder cup
valff a sonné mais c'est à dire qu'en
gros il ya déjà il ya déjà sept cette
notion de frapper de balle et naturel de
tourner autour de la kz2 l'ex du corps
pour envoyer la balle le plus loin
possible et en plus d'après ce que dit
son père il y prend du plaisir et il est
déjà il est déjà concentré peut-être pas
tout le temps mais en tout cas quand il
rate un coup il s'y remet ici remet tout
de suite il reconcentre il se
reconcentre ça ça c'est déjà pas facile
à faire et c'est le golf formidable
école de la vie pour sa part un côté
contré le geste il est comment le reste
il est bien mais le geste on passe notre
vie c'est de perfectionner et les pros
aussi évidente aussi souvent mais mais
c'est pour moi le plus important c'est
que pour lui c'est normal ça lui plaît
il va il fait ce qu'il aime et
l'important quand un enfant a trouvé le
sport qu'ils aiment c'est qu'il y va
avec plaisir qu'il partage donc avec
plaisir qu'ils rencontrent d'autres
enfants il ya un vecteur de lien social
dans le sport qui est capital et donc il
faut profiter de ça quand votre enfant a
trouvé un sport qu'ils aiment encourager
le soutenez le et voilà et j'en profite
pour rappeler que en 2022 comme depuis
longtemps à saint quentin nous offrons
des journées et des soirées golf
expérience sur les parcours du
territoire national il a levé la golf
blue green de l'île de loisirs avec des
moments de découverte du golf ça a
beaucoup de succès bout de championnat
par équipes des championnats du monde
par ignacio matin on a la nationale
golfweek en avril au bataillon il ya
tout ce qu'il faut pour se mettre au
golf à saint quentin vraiment facilement
dans venez okba hezil ce sport qui est
un sport pierre l'a dit qu'on peut
pratiquer toute sa vie et on peut le
pratiquer en famille parce qu'on partage
ne s'affrontent pas directement ses
tapas fort dessus on est à côté on
marche on passe un bon moment du tout
pendant ma retraite ce sera compliqué et
que tu sais exactement ce que j'aurais
fait du coup ce petit georges du coup
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire non c'est
c'est beau à voir c'est comment tous ces
petits enfants qui découvrent quelque
chose de nouveau et et puis et puis
aussi ses fondamentaux de pratiquer
quelque chose dès le bas âge c'est
toujours et c'est toujours bien parce
que on développe pas mal de choses donc
l'angoissé c'est bien et puis après on
voit qu'il ya une volonté de développer
le golf en général en france et puis
dans la région la nouvelle région pour
jouer au golf donc il faut le faire et
quand on pense enfants qui a découvert
le golf très tôt très jeune on pense
forcément à ta gueule on va peut-être
voir les images tailleur mousse tout
petit os il avait deux de trois ans
parce qu'en même âge est ce que vous
pensez que georges peut suivre sa
trajectoire ou c'est trop tôt encore
pour le dire difficile à dire ce qu'il
peut oui qu'est-ce qui le fera à sens et
par mes
passions avec heures avec le père un
père good ce qui était déjà qu'ils
étaient déjà bien bien focus sur la
performance ça a donné cette carrière
monumentale d'ailleurs à malgré son
accident tailleur est de retour avec son
fils et son fils arrive cela sur deux
pays si il allait les 2e et 2e il
apprend on puce deuxième quand même
le petit j'allais gérer ce qu'il faut
pour garder la relève est assurée donc
on sait pas si ce ce petit georges aura
le même destin on lui souhaite
après c'est bien pour le golf en france
et pour les objets de manière générale
c'est déjà à la fin de cette émission va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui on termine par une
citation de la légende de la boxe
mohammed ali qui a la même vision du
monde à 20 ans qu'à 50 ans a perdu 30
ans de sa vie fia je vous laisse méditer
sur cette phrase très belles fêtes de
fin d'année sur tv 78 où
[Musique]